de moreau l'un de ses plus grands
festivals électro de tous les temps donc
est il plus grands festivals d'électro
dit les plus grands dédiée du monde au
rendez vous plus de 190 personnes qui
viennent de 75 pays différents et les
feuilles de plus belle à la planète
alors pour vous donner une petite idée
sur youtube via une vidéo récapitulative
du tomorrowland 2012 et je peux vous
dire que quand tu commences la vidéo tu
es comme ça et comme tu l'affinité
plutôt comme ça
[Applaudissements]
alors y at il un truc chelou je trouve
avec tomorrowland c'est que le festival
s'est trouvé en belgique
tuez moi j'ai un petit bug à chaque fois
que je me rappelle que c'est en belgique
la loi
je prends la pastèque alors quand j'ai
appris ça j'ai pas tout de suite compris
pourquoi la belgique mais je pense qu'il
ya un truc comme ça qui est juste passé
comme mahdia jdd ouais on va créer le
festival électro le plus grand du monde
et ce en faisant belgique c'est cool la
belgique
nicolas tu arrêtes de dire des bêtises
s'il te plaît au fait c'est quoi ce
bordel
bah quoi tu aimes pas des frites vas-y
bah ouais mais je suis pas un très vieux
monsieur nicolas bay mais bravo monsieur
bravo lorsque j'ai appris que tu as des
dizaines de milliers de places qui sont
réservées aux belges alors le rapport
logique entre ces deux éléments je pense
qu'il est vite fait alors écoutons tu
veux courir pour me laisser contre et
euroland sur ton territoire
évidemment ça ne rapportera des millions
en plus tu m'entends oui toute attaque
dagen ta gueule tu peux juste répond
vous nous réservez 80000 places alors
enfin on déplace à plus 200 euros pour
les trois jours ajoute à ça le prix pour
aller jusqu'en belgique le prix vont
rester sur place et pas dormir par terre
dans l'herbe en train de mourir dans son
vomi avec des dizaines de milliers de
personnes qui se foutent de ta gueule
donc là tu arrive plus à 450 ban 4 200
je trouve quand même hein donc c'était
en hd tune tu as plutôt intérêt à
s'accrocher pour trouver l'argent quand
même [ __ ] je t'emmène pour 5 euros
non plutôt taillé pour 5 s'est jamais
été réussie a récolté 450 bureaux d'un
petit job qui tu rapportes assez pour
pouvoir te payer ça c'est pas encore
gagné à nantes gadal les 188 bien ça sur
les cent mille places qu'elle est ce
parce que on a quatre amis pour les
belges ton mais en même temps en vente
sur le site officiel le 16 février à 17
heures donc quand tu sais que tu as des
gens de 75 pays différents qui veulent y
aller
et tu as deux millions personnes
connectées sur le site autant dire que
les places partent en cinq minutes
c'est à dire que si tu es sous la douche
en train de manger ou dans son jardin en
train de passer la tondeuse t'es dans la
merde total
[Musique]
donc j'imagine un peu la déception tu
dois voir comment ça fait six mois que
tu as prévu le truc que d'abbas et ont
permis d'aller de l'argent de côté et
tous n'ont en revanche si tu es majeur
que tu as assez d'aplomb honda était
parmi les chanceux qui ont réussi à
choper une place matt ce qui t'attend
mon gars répondent toutes aux bras
[Musique]
m
c'est du crime le numéro 4 une substance
illicite a été déposée sur ce seul qui
puisse être très drôle suspect numéro un